Speaker 1: We are going to speak to a couple
of other people here.
Let's go to Toni from Philly.
Toni from Philly.
You're on the air.
Hello.
Speaker 4: Hello.
And if I was there,
Speaker 1: you sound like you're completely
underwater, what are you saying?
Speaker 2: How about that, do I sound better
now?
Speaker 1: You know, now it's perfectly clear,
yeah, OK.
Speaker 2: What?
Well, first off, how are you, David?
How are you doing?
I'm doing fine.
Thank you.
Last time I called in, we actually spoke about
reparations, and I was a little upset because
you titled the video.
Caller argues about reparations, and it was
more for discussion and not an argument, but
OK.
Speaker 1: All right.
Well, we'll investigate
Speaker 2: small, small potatoes.
You know, sometimes those are, you know, I
enjoyed my discussion with you about it.
Good.
It wasn't.
There wasn't any real issue that I had with
you labeling it that way.
Just a little
Speaker 1: joke.
All right.
What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: I wanted to say how I think what
we need to do is really amend the Constitution
to get 50 percent control of the corporate
boards of directors in order to really get
control over this political environment.
I think people need to be in direct control
of the workplace, and that's the natural next
step.
OK, let's
Speaker 1: explore.
Let's explore what you mean.
OK?
Get control of 50 percent who for who to control
50 percent of boards of directors of the
Speaker 2: employee and an employee board
of directors.
Pretty much almost like like a union, except
they would have direct control.
50 percent direct control.
So, you
Speaker 1: know, half the seats.
Let's talk through it calmly so we can understand
it.
Half the seats of the corporation's board
of directors would be held by employees that
presumably are not executives, right?
It's the workers.
Yes.
OK.
And once a company reaches what size would
this start like, I'm guessing this wouldn't
apply to like tiny little businesses,
Speaker 2: only publicly traded companies
or only publicly traded or a company that
controls way too much of the market share
for a given industry.
Speaker 1: What about like a huge nonprofit
with a thousand employees that's not publicly
traded?
Would it apply to them as well?
Speaker 2: You know, honestly, I haven't thought
it out that far.
Hmm.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
I mean, I like this idea.
This is when we talk about democratization
of the workplace outside of the context of
me being.
Not of me not being.
I'm not a socialist.
So just saying the workers just automatically
own the company.
And that's it.
There's no more private ownership.
I'm not a socialist, so I don't support that.
But when we talk about democratization of
the workplace saying that after a certain
level, it is required to have employee representation
on a board.
That's a great idea.
That's exactly the type of thing that I find
interesting.
So you know, when you when you say we need
a constitutional amendment, I don't know if
it's done constitutionally.
Corporations are typically registered at individual
states.
Maybe it's a state by state thing.
I don't know the legality of it, but I'm fascinated
by the idea.
I think you were thinking, we're thinking
big ideas here.
Speaker 2: OK, well, thank you for your time,
I appreciate it, I just wanted to bring it
up to you and see if I could get a yay or
nay out of you.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
Thank you so much for the call.
Very much.
Appreciate it.
That's going to do it for today.
We took some great calls.
We will take calls again and we will now go
to a very short break and then be back with
more of today's show.